quebec-based medicago's kovafens is a
point of canadian pride it's the first
homegrown coven 19 vaccine to be
approved by health canada and the first
plant-derived vaccine to hit the market
ever but now it's facing a disappointing
rejection by the who which warned this
would happen it's well known that double
joe and u.n has a very strict policy
regarding the
engagement with tobacco and arms
industry medicago is partially owned by
the world's largest tobacco company
phillip morris international maricago
says it's been trying to distance itself
since july of 2020. takashi negao
mericago's president and ceo said in a
statement the company is aware the
vaccine status is not accepted and that
the decision was linked to its minority
shareholder not as a result of kovafen's
safety or efficacy menicago is still
waiting on details and rationale before
taking next steps
canada has a deal for 76 million doses
of cova fence they plan to donate many
of them to the global vaccine sharing
program known as kovacs the rejection by
the who will make donations difficult
bioethicist carrie bowman says the need
to make vaccines available to those who
haven't yet received them should
outweigh any ethics issues the who has
with medical's ties to the tobacco giant
one of the challenges particularly for
low-income countries it's not just
supply anymore it's infrastructure and
it's vaccine hesitancy we need every
single tool we can get and this is a
very good vaccine
and it's got a lot of benefits
particularly for some not all but people
that are vaccine hesitant canada has
promised 200 million doses to kovacs so
far just 37 million have been donated
the federal government says it's working
with medical to come up with a solution
in canada cove offends is approved for
ages 18 to 64. jamie morocco global news
toronto